[Applause]
[Music]
yeah happy
Monday oh thank you thank you please
please just hand your gifts over to the
Usher so when the presidents of Harvard
MIT and the University of Pennsylvania
are exposed as Dumb Dumber and dumbest
it's a great day for all of us in case
you missed it these three leading
educrats were grilled like brat wor at a
tailgate by Congress last week on the
issue of
genocide specifically calling for the
genocide of Jews does that constitute
bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision calling for the genocide of
Jews does not constitute bullying and
harassment I have not heard calling for
for the genocide for Jews on our campus
but you've heard chance for
inata I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context at
Harvard does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no it can be
depending on the context genocide people
the systematic extermination of an
entire group of people or as Hitler
called it the most fun you can have with
your pants
on
yet somehow Curly MO and Larry just
couldn't find their way to renounce it
you know because standing against mass
murder can be a tough call you know it's
like they were being asked to define a
woman as you know the president of upen
has already stepped down it's a start
but the other two are hanging around
like a fart and kill me's private
elevator yeah it's private
elevator and stomach
issues Harvard's president Claudine gay
issued a supposed ly clarifying
statement that was about as clear as
Ikea directions to assemble a spaceship
and it's likely not the only crap she's
going to have to answer for according to
a report from researcher Chris rufo gay
plagiarized sections of her PhD
dissertation in
1997 if true while on her path to become
head administrator she violated the
school's policy on academic Integrity
does it matter well it didn't back then
I wonder why now anyone who watched
these hearings saw the worst televised
answers since that time Dana was on
Jeopardy uh name a movie for 2000 please
in a 1982 charmer I'll be right here
Dana sorry Haley Joel osman's I see dead
people Dana what is the Exorcist no for
our final today we are dealing with
museums and this cluee completed in
1959 it's been variously described as a
snail a concrete tornado even a giant
wedding cake did you get this oh you
weren't able to do and it'll cost you
how much 3,200 so you drop down to
zero there's really no reason to include
that in this
monologue none
whatsoever happy holidays so the whole
spectacle was laugh out loud funny
unlike Saturday night lives take boy did
that stink it was so bad even KLA Harris
stopped laughing SNL's new motto
shouldn't be live from New York it
should be dead from the neck up but this
hearing was important for more than just
cleaning house it finally Shine the
Light on those leading our young people
and into an increasingly competitive
future and what we saw is a system that
defined speech suppression as free
speech and threats as tolerance you know
everyone's opinion is viewed as violence
except those that call for violence
which makes about as much sense as
paying 150 Grand to send your brat to a
place that will send him home a Marxist
who hates your guts but now you have no
excuse for not knowing how bad it is see
if you saw those hearings you felt your
IQ dropping faster than Joe Biden's body
temperature especially when they said
calling for genocide is fine as long as
it doesn't lead to action in other words
the university doesn't need to resp
respond unless the killing starts that's
quite a red line to wait for you know
the beginning of the murder of
Jews but why do I feel like that would
be explained away too of course if as
we're told the people shouting for
genocide don't really mean it we have to
ask ourselves what do they mean are
these rhetorical protests are we being
punked somehow I'm inclined to believe
them when they call for the genocide of
a nation that was just subjected to an
explosion of murder and sexual
atrocities see there's the context
because really what the protesters are
saying is we'll have more of that please
I'm pretty sure the Jewish students at
these schools don't find all this
rhetorical but what about the other
students maybe to them it's no big deal
because they're as brain dead as their
teachers a recent Wall Street Journal
poll showed that while almost 90% of
college students support the Palestinian
chant from The River To The Sea
essentially calling for Israel's
eradication less than half could name
which river they were referring to I
mean what do they think from River to
the Sea means a good deal on real estate
in South
Florida less than a quarter knew who
former Palestinian Authority president
yaser Arafat was over 10% thought he was
the first prime minister of Israel the
rest heard Arafat and thought it was a
slam at obesity and condemned it as fat
shaming that was a joke
people
so these School presidents have always
been loud and proud against Injustice
and hate speech but now all of a sudden
it depends on the context but the
context they're ignoring is October 7th
don't they realize this is how Holocaust
actually happened explaining away calls
for genocide using context meanwhile
these great Educators brainwash our
young with a hateful view of the world
comprised solely of oppressed versus
oppressor meanwhile in an they're
wasting time on math science and
computer skills don't those damn Chinese
realize we got a global pronoun
problem so ask yourself if all this
miseducation is damaging the nation why
do these scammers cling to it so much
because it works for them October 7th
was the flashlight that finally exposed
the full Dei scam these incompetents
only got their jobs based on the same
ideology that makes justification for
October 7th possible so don't expect
them to give it up like my teacher did
on prom
night they have to make sure someone
genuinely qualified can never get their
job and if you still doubt that these
three are morons ask yourself this they
thought those answers in public would
actually work they actually said that
Harvard Embraces free expression of all
views right this is at a school where
all students have to attend orientation
where they're told fat phobia is
violence and that using the wrong
pronoun is abuse where a whopping
1.46% of the faculty actually Define
themselves as conservative where Harvard
plays 248th out of 248 schools in a
ranking of Campus Free Speech right
behind Kim Jong-un Community
College Claudine gay has done and will
do nothing to fix any of of this nor
will any other college President
professor and administrators who see it
as their jobs to indoctrinate instead of
educate and when they start claiming
they're being silenced remember that
they're whining that the intimidation
used to silence people is what's being
silenced thankfully we found the best
way to reveal them as idiots let him
speak then show them the
door let's welcome tonight
guest his writing is so sharp pilcs
avoid his books novelist and literary
critic Walter
Kerr to her every date is a speed date
host of the fox True Crime podcast Emily
[Music]
capano his 25 years at Fox Pro that our
viewers are heart of hearing host of one
nation in author of the new book Teddy
and Booker T how to
America kill
me and she's bony Stony and loved by
your Uncle Tony New York Times
bestselling author and fox contributor
cat
Walter okay so you got the upen
president Liz mckill is already out the
door what about this other one M gay
who's been accused of
plagiarism well see I don't think that
the fact that there are a few um copied
paragraphs in her PhD thesis proves
plagiarism but it does prove that no one
ever read it
um including maybe the person who
supposedly wrote it um and it certainly
proves that no one expected to read it
she she didn't it's like going to the
bathroom in the woods you know who
thinks you're going to get caught right
um and uh but there was a park range
behind a tree in this case yes and um
she did get caught and uh the problem is
that how would she know it's plagiarism
because these kind of thesis these
social justice style thesis they all
sound the same anyway it's everything's
plagarism they use the same words the
same ideas you wouldn't recognize it um
but I I think the mistake of the college
presidents in general was that they came
as a threesome um they all sat together
they came over in a car and it was like
you're the coolest no you're the coolest
you know I'm Harvard I'm pen you
and what they and what they forgot was
context on the context of the Harvard
campus everything's genocide okay
questioning Elizabeth Warren's Cherokee
Heritage is genocide at Harvard um but
in the context of you know the The World
At Large normal people especially people
whose grandparents died in concentration
camps genocide still mean something and
they got a little confused so they
shouldn't they shouldn't have come as a
group also they were so stupid didn't
they realize three ivy league presidents
in a row everybody's going to hate you
yeah make some attempt to seem human but
they didn't that's cuz they hired a law
firm they didn't two of them hired the
same Law Firm to coach them so they
didn't even trust their own thoughts it
struck me that feces rhymes with
feces I'm somehow going to work that
into everything that I do GRE Greg there
any other ivy league graduates here
again or is it just me
again isn't that great how you work that
in because I do want to say you'll
notice that the president of Princeton
wasn't there yeah and I went to
Princeton and he wasn't there because
we're smart at Princeton at Harvard they
think they're smart and they try to
prove it to everyone Princeton we know
it and we keep it to
ourselves except on TV exactly Emily how
come they had such a hard time saying
genocide is like a violation of their
conduct that that's the whole question I
mean to your point it's like the
anti-semitic witches of eastw with come
coming into the Congressional hearings
and for some reason they are unable to
just declare with confidence yes this is
anti-Semitic yes this is uncalled FL
instead of dancing around and talking
about how the exception could be
harassment why can't they say yes that's
harassment yes that's unacceptable and
there are a few exceptions where context
matters I don't understand here how they
were so quickly to air on the side of
what isn't hate speech what isn't a
terrible crime when everything out of
their mouths normally is calling out
what is a hate crime and what is
criminal so misgendering someone
according to these people is truly
criminal right calling someone a
different gender that is considered
violent telling someone that they're
pro- life or or expressing your view
that you are pro-life even just being a
white male that is violent direct quotes
from these people in their institutions
but I think that wsj had a good oped
today where yes the mask comes off they
say about these reg resignations and
hopefully two more to follow but that's
just the tip of the iceberg because the
problem obviously is the rut that
happens at these institutions that is
now multi-generational so the
president's resigning absolves a little
bit I guess of some money but know where
your tax dollars go for these public
colleges know where your tuition monies
go for the colleges that you send your
kids to and at the end of the day know
what rot is permeating our social fabric
because these chicks are just the
mouthpieces for what is horrible
anti-Semitism but them stepping down is
only the tip of the
iceberg Iceberg a Jewish name
um Brian it looks like it looks like one
resigned one might follow have you
considered resigning a lot of people my
res Brian has resign from Fox and
Friends like they'll go where's Brian's
uh Brian's on his office he's on the
second floor trying to resign they just
won't accept it uh and it's just some I
don't I'm a little offended by she used
the word females for chicks yes why do
you accept it on this show don't you
have any standards number I mean you
should I mean we'll talk about it after
I guess yes yeah uh how long will the
post show meeting be I don't know we do
usually a three-hour post show meeting
we just go through everything yeah uh
couple of things this is the zoom moment
of of college and I don't think it's
just about these three schools I think
it's about college Elite colleges in
general I just don't think it's about
these presidents I actually don't care
if they resigned they're doing exactly
what they were hired to do they weren't
wild catting it in front of the country
they were being themselves in front of
the country and they were exposed so now
instead of Republicans or conservatives
or people who are just patriotic
concerned about the future of the
country saying what's going on in our
schools and people saying oh there's a
culture Warrior now the rest of the
country is going what's going on with
our schools this is a little out of
control and these presidents I don't
look at as the problem I look at as they
represent the problem I don't care if
she gets fired but I'm sure you saw 660
Harvard faculty member sign saying she
should not get fired which backs up the
fear everybody has is that in colleges
it's poison and I think from High Point
to and not to call out a North Carolina
school but an average everyday school up
until the mits have to be looked at and
I think we should do this Greg maybe you
could start it because you have so much
free time I do a woke a woke a woke
rating on only school yeah that's a
great idea W creting that's great do you
want to take it as yours or are you just
you have a very low woke rating Brian
because no one's awake when you're
on cat agree that was a sick
burn huh sick burn cat job thank you
thanks what do you make of this whole
thing well I am a free speech absolutist
so I still am okay uh even the most
hateful vile hate speech is
constitutionally producted under the
first Amendment I'm always going to say
that the answer to speech that you don't
like even if it's disgusting is more
speech and not moving to censor that
speech that makes me a consistent human
being uh the consistency does not apply
to Harvard and upen obviously as you
brought up uh the foundation for
individual rights and educa um
expression used to be education they
rank schools based on Free Speech as you
mentioned and upen was second to last
and then Harvard was dead last so
clearly for them it's this is these are
new things that they're saying and Emily
as you as you said that if you misgender
someone or use the wrong pronouns we'll
say that as violence I'm the kind of
person that doesn't feel comfortable
giving anyone that kind of power to say
because this person feels this way about
this we we're going to have to ban this
so that's just me being consistent and I
and I don't think there should be an
environment on campuses where there
censor censoring constitutionally
protected speech so I still feel that
way um there is hypocrisy here though
obviously mhm you think graduating from
an IV leag school now being negative
like I got bad news I graduated from y
I'm so sorry to I got into one and then
I couldn't afford to go and I'm like
okay I didn't miss out on much right now
you know bar stool will not hire anybody
from an i League school and most people
aspire to go right from Harvard to bar
that is
true all right we got to move on shout
out to the iceberg
family they're a cold group go pen hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else